In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 10th, on which we commemorate the Holy
Marters, Minodora, Mitrodora and Nymphodora.
On the 10th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Marters, Minodora, Mitrodora
and Nymphodora.
These three blessed sisters, according to the flesh, lived in Bethinia in the reign of
Galerius Maximian, circa the years, 305 through 311, surpassingly beautiful, as well
in soul as in body.
They were drawn by the love of Christ to a place in the mountains called Pithia, where there
were hot water springs.
In this retirement, far from mankind and every worldly care, they spent their days cultivating
the flowers of the divine virtues and delighting in the honey of contemplation.
The Holy Spirit took up his abode in them, and, before long, many came to them seeking
healing of physical and spiritual diseases.
The fame of these holy women reached the ears of Fronto, the governor of the region, who
sent a passie of soldiers to bring them in, so that under examination they might be forced
to deny Christ.
Their wisdom and steadfastness amazed him, but seeing that nothing would persuade them to
abandon their beloved bridegroom, he had Minodora stripped, and beaten relentlessly
until she gave up her soul to the Lord, praying to her last breath.
Then, sending for her sisters, he showed them the bruised and naked body of Minodora to
frighten them, and to weaken their resolve, but the sight only increased their determination
to undertake the final contest in their turn.
So, Minodora and Ninfodora departed likewise.
Their bodies burnt with torches, and their limbs shattered by bars of iron, to join the choir
of wise virgins in the nuptial chamber of the heavenly bridegroom.
The calm and joyful demeanor of the saints as they bore their sufferings enraged the
governor.
He tried to burn their relics, to prevent their veneration, but a violent storm arose
and put out the fire at the very moment their bodies were cast into the furnace, so the faithful
were able to give them honorable burial.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.